[Applauso]
[Musica]
Avete visto l'ultimo video della maestra
cattiva Chissà chi sarà oggi il nostro
nuovo insegnante Spero non quella
dell'altra volta era troppo cattiva come
maestra io non lo voglio
fumo questo
Io sono il vostro insegnante
e oggi vi mancano i cervelli ah ah ah
Ah
meno che non supererete le mie prove ma
prima ci vuole un assaggio
tu vieni qui No
ho detto
oh no lo zombie ci ha rinchiuso in
prigione è una nuova Escape Room
dobbiamo scappare dalla prigione dello
zombie
qualcosa che figata questo vuol dire che
dobbiamo aprire solo una porta non due
capisci è vero
[Musica]
sta arrivando
adesso che vi ho morso di trasformerete
in zombie come me
A meno che non supererete le mie tre
Challenge in quel caso però
l'antidoto ma state attenti perché da un
momento all'altro potrei mangiarvi il
cervello
si svolgerà il cervello
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ma qual è la prima Challenge la prima
Challenge sarà scappare dalla prigione
attenti perché se non dovesse riuscirvi
[Musica]
i vostri cervelli avete capito Siete
pronti via
[Musica]
prima Challenge dobbiamo scappare dalla
prigione Ma la porta è chiusa dobbiamo
trovare la chiave
ma noi le chiavi
come facciamo ad attirarlo e prendergli
la chiave mi è venuto l'ideale lo posso
tirare io ti dico guarda Ehi Zombie
vieni a prendermi il cervello Vieni
vieni
no è troppo pericoloso potrebbe
mangiarti il cervello davvero cerchiamo
qualcosa ok
Anita io qui non trovo niente Tu hai
trovato qualcosa no gli unici oggetti
sono fuori dalla prigione Qui c'è una
Trombetta magari se la premo succederà
qualcosa
che cos'era
uno scarafaggio non sono stato io Anita
non può essere che la trombetta faccia
apparire le cose guarda la lipriamo e
vedrai che non è così
[Musica]
Questa è la chiave per prendere le
chiavi dobbiamo utilizzare Lo
scarafaggio il martello giusto perché è
uno zombie piacciono le cose schifose lo
attiriamo con Lo scarafaggio è Boom una
botta in testa
e Zombie o qualcosa per te vieni
Ma cos'è questo muro profumino Ma questo
è uno scarafaggio croccante
ha funzionato bravo ora prendiamo le
chiavi sono lì
presa presto
prima che si svegli
lucchetto aperto via libera
è un po' difficile qua dobbiamo passare
sopra lo zombie
prendo
Ah ah ah aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
No no aiuto e mollala l'acqua Oh quella
roba Verdello
No sono riusciti a scappare ma con la
prossima Challenge sono sicuro di farli
fuori
[Applauso]
[Musica]
E ora per la seconda Challenge ho
preparato due pulsanti Ognuno di loro
avrà una prova una più spaventosa
dell'altra Ma voi non saprete quale sarà
quale per passare la seconda Challenge
dovete vincere tutte le prove altrimenti
non vi darò l'antidoto e vi
trasformerete in zombie Siete pronti
via allora chi lo prende il gusto tenero
io lo premi Tu premi tu prima tu e
perché lo devo prendere prima io e
perché lo devo prendere la prima io
perché magari prendi solo problemi per
prima tu ma magari io la sfida difficile
qua c'è la sfida facile e magari io c'ho
la sfida facile e Tu lo premi per prima
quindi lo premi per prima tu prendi la
prima volta
[Musica]
il tasto mi ha portato in questa sfida
nel pavimento ci sono delle lettere dei
numeri ogni volta che le colpe state
Dovrete dire una parola che inizi con
quella lettera ma se sbagliate la parola
ci sarà una penitenza quindi dovrete
arrivare fino alla fine Pronti Via
ok Non lo so se ho capito Io scelgo la
elefante
Giusto Ora tocca a me io
la uccidi
cervelli così la mia preferita No i
cervelli ho scelto la
Ahia Arcobaleno
Giusto giusto tocca a me adesso
Peppe Peppe di farfalla stiamo andando
bene signora grande e no una già pronta
Ti stupirò Guarda ho scelto la cappa
KD accappatoio no
accappatoio non c'è la cappa in
accappatoio come non c'è la k h voglio
accappatoio lo dice la parola stessa Oh
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Nel frattempo io stavo ho cliccato
un'altra Casellina
una parola con la j jeans
Ah che schifo lo senti questa puzza
di cacca
Vabbè tocca a me adesso io scelgo la g g
di giardino
tocca a me adesso voglio provare a
prendere una scorciatoia vado alla D
e
di
[Musica]
no no non mi viene in mente niente con
la t ah
tempo scaduto penitenza di come dita di
mostro
[Musica]
Oh le dita Vi mostro Adesso
sbrighiamoci a finire questa Challenge
Che schifo tocca a me e io scelgo la R
la r di raggio di sole ma devi dire solo
raggio allora
vero Zombie vero
Te la sei scampata tocca a me adesso
vidi volante
[Musica]
salva su Sì no qualcosa Non mi viene in
mente niente
Andiamo nella casellina finale Anche
perché non voglio più le dita da mostro
sappiamo insieme va bene uno due uno
ce l'abbiamo fatta Sì abbiamo superato
la prima prova Siamo tornati qua
avete superato la prima prova ma adesso
c'è la seconda quindi premeditato se no
niente niente
[Musica]
delle carte e per questa seconda prova
della seconda Challenge dovrete fare un
castello con le carte e dovrete farelo
prima che scala il tempo ed è
impossibile Pronti Via non credo che sia
così difficile il castello con le carte
come quello di sabbia ma non c'è la
sabbia ci sono le carte proviamo presto
prima che scade il tempo
[Musica]
Ma mi hai buttato giù
dai Vieni qua
[Musica]
tanto mi mettere due prima non è vero
è difficilissimo
Anzi Vabbè con i piedi queste carte
Brava Anita Ottima idea
[Musica]
dove ha fatto il castello di carta prova
a farla ancora più grande
piano vai piano
prendilo
però l'importante è che ce l'abbiamo
fatta
terza prova della seconda Challenge
prendete i pulsanti E scoprirete che
cosa è
[Musica]
proviamolo insieme 1 2
avete premuto il tasto insieme e ora ci
sarà la prova estrema con questa sfera
elettrica posso creare i fulmini in
questa stanza e Voi dovrete evitare
oppure verrete
[Applauso]
e adesso il colpo finale
[Musica]
No non funziona più
avete superato la terza sfida della
seconda Challenge ma adesso la terza
Challenge
[Musica]
terza Challenge dovrete scappare da me e
arrivare fino al traguardo ma se dovessi
prendervi vi mangerò il cervellino
E farò di tutto per riuscirci Pronti Via
[Musica]
corri corri corri
corri
no tornate qui
abbiamo superato il traguardo ragazzi di
antidoto
stupido
No va bene Avete vinto voi
avete vinto l'antidoto prendete
gelatina sopra presto vediamolo
com'è schifoso sbrigati
[Musica]
Speriamo che
funzionissimo Pensavate di essere salvi
E adesso che avete bevuto l'antidoto
invece no perché io mi mangerò Comunque
il cervello ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
cosa hai fatto Ah ah ah ah
[Musica]
lo zombie con l'antidoto zombie